even if you've never seen the ocean or
touched the ocean that the ocean touches
you every breath you take every drop of
water you drink is the ocean is the
ocean for me being a biologist just
following my heart has led me to some
fascinating places
but has held my attention all these
years it's life in the ocean that's
where most of life on Earth actually
lives as a scientist I'd love nothing
more than being an explorer discovering
the nature of life itself
that sense of Eureka scientists are like
little kids who never quite grew up
don't ever stop asking who what why
where when how they beat whales and
dolphins ask some of these questions but
they may wonder what stars are and they
may wonder what's in the depths of the
ocean below where they swim but only
humans have the capacity to really
answer those questions
and we think only about 10% of the ocean
has been seen or sampled at all we're
just beginning to assess the magnitude
of our ignorance and at the same time
that we're learning more we're also
discovering how much we're losing how do
you save the ocean we find others who
have a similar goal and together we find
ways means of working with people who
have the power to make decisions that
ultimately result in protection for a
place that you love that's how it
happens
all of us depend on these ecosystems and
they're incredibly in some ways they're
incredibly resilient if we do the right
thing but they're also it's a magical
sight
an endless horizon that just stretches
out to blue infinity and it jump in the
ocean and there you find happiness
one every five breaths you take come
from this tiny little organism called
Peron Laura campus they produce 20% of
the oxygen in the atmosphere